يتكشف الوضع اليائس في
أكبر مستشفى في غزة، مستشفى ألفا،
وقد علمنا للتو أن
ثلاثة أطفال رضع في وحدة الأطفال حديثي الولادة
توفوا بعد أن خرج المستشفى من
الخدمة، وتقول وزارة الصحة التي تديرها حماس
إن الأطفال الرضع ماتوا بعد أن
تسبب التدريع القريب في تعطل المولد الكهربائي.  اخرج
بن ويدمان من CNN يتابع
لنا هذه القصة أه من جنوب لبنان أه
بن هذا المستشفى حيوي للأشخاص
الذين يعيشون في أه شمال غزة
منظمة الصحة العالمية تسمي هذا في الواقع
أهم منشأة صحية في
غزة أم أخبرنا المزيد عن أه هذا
المستشفى وما نعرفه عما
يحدث
هناك جيدًا هو مستشفى الشفاء وهو
أكبر مستشفى في غزة، وقد
عولجت هناك بعد أن أطلقت
القوات الإسرائيلية النار عليها في أكتوبر/تشرين الأول 2000، وهو
أفضل منشأة طبية في غزة ولكن
الوضع هناك بكل المقاييس سيئ.
كارثية وتزداد سوءا تمكنت سي إن إن من
التحدث مع مدير
عام وزارة الصحة في
غزة منير بو وقال إن الشفاء في
هذه المرحلة محاصرة بالكامل أه
من القوات الإسرائيلية والدبابات الإسرائيلية وهناك
طائرات إسرائيلية بدون طيار تحلق فوقها لا يمكن
لأي شخص أن يحاول  للخروج أه
المباني هناك عدة مباني
تشكل المجمع الذي هو
مستشفى الشفاء أي شخص يخطو إلى
الخارج يتعرض لإطلاق النار الآن هناك
20 ألف شخص أه يلجأون إلى
المستشفى نفسه بالإضافة إلى 400
مريض يعالجهم الأطباء
نفهم أن المولدات التي
تزود
المستشفى بالكهرباء إما نفذ منها الوقود أو
تضررت أه من الضربات الإسرائيلية
نتيجة توقف وحدة العناية المركزة
ووحدة الأطفال وأجهزة الأكسجين عن
العمل وأساسا ما
نفهمه من الناس  في المستشفى،
يوجد 36 طفلًا في
المستشفى يتم إبقاؤهم على قيد الحياة بواسطة
جهاز تنفس يدوي، لذلك يتعين على الموظفين
ضخ الأكسجين والهواء باستمرار
إلى رئتي هؤلاء الأطفال البالغ عددهم 36 طفلًا، والآن
أصبح الموظفون مرهقين تمامًا في الوقت الحالي بالإضافة إلى ذلك
ببساطة
كمية أه المعركة التي تدور
حول المستشفى قلة المستلزمات
قلة الغذاء الماء الكهرباء
وبالإضافة إلى ذلك هناك عشرات
الجثث لأشخاص
قتلوا وهي في الأساس مكدسة
خارج المستشفى ولكن  ولا يمكن
دفنهم بسبب القتال
الدائر حولهم